ahora vamos a elevar el número cero a
distintas potencias aunque entonces
vamos a empezar con un cero elevado a la
1 y entonces yo te pregunto a ti cuánto
crees tú que debería de valer 0 elevado
a la 1 entonces pone pausa piensa muy
bien en tu respuesta y ya después le
pones play
ok supongamos que ya me dijiste cuánto
vale 0 a la 1 entonces nosotros tenemos
una definición para cuánto vale un
número elevado a la 1 y esto es igual a
pues siempre que tenemos un número
elevado a la 1 podemos escoger la
segunda definición que vimos de los
exponentes y decir que esto es igual a
un 1 multiplicando el número que estamos
elevando alguna potencia la cantidad de
veces que nos diga el exponente aunque
hay entonces aquí tenemos un 1 y esto lo
que nos dice es que tenemos que
multiplicar a un 1
pero una sola vez entonces aquí tenemos
1 por 0 una sola vez y esto es igual a
cero porque 0 por cualquier cosa es cero
aunque entonces 0 elevado a la potencia
1 es simplemente un cero muy bien ahora
vamos a ver cuánto vale 0 al cuadrado ok
pero al cuadrado es lo mismo que decir 0
a la segunda potencia y eso es igual a
alguna propuesta esto es igual a 1 por
pues tenemos que multiplicar a este 1
por 0 2 veces
gray por 0 y x
y esto como tenemos un 0 multiplicando a
otras cosas y cualquier cosa por 0 es 0
entonces todo esto tiene que ser igual a
0 y bueno me imagino que ya sabes
exactamente cuál es el patrón que se
sigue aquí que es que si tenemos 0 y lo
elevamos a cualquier potencia distinta
de 0 lo elevamos a cualquiera
número distinto de 0 que ponemos aquí
este símbolo para decir que es distinto
de 0 pero bueno el chiste es que 0
elevado a cualquier potencia distinta de
0 cualquier número distinto de 0 eso
siempre nos va a quedar igual a cero
ahora esto hace que surja una pregunta
muy interesante que es cuánto debería de
valer 0 elevado a la cero porque mira 0
elevado a la un millón 999.999 es 060
elevado a las 5 a la 8 todas las
potencias distintas de 0 de 0 nos da un
0 pero si ponemos
0 elevado a la potencia 0 entonces
tenemos un caso muy interesante si es
que yo propongo que le vuelvas a poner
pausa al vídeo y lo pienses con calma ya
ya lo pensaste muy bien bueno el chiste
es que hay dos formas de pensar en esto
por un lado tenemos que 0 elevado a
cualquier número incluso no hemos
hablado de esto todavía y vamos a
hacerlo eventualmente pero 0 elevado a
alguna fracción también es igual a 0
pero por otro lado habíamos visto hace
algunos vídeos que si tenemos cualquier
número distinto de cero
distinto de 0 y lo elevamos a la
potencia 0 este número lo encontramos
tomando un 1 y multiplicando por este
número distinto de 0 0 veces
osea en realidad no estamos
multiplicando nada así es que se queda
este 1 solito y entonces podríamos
querer extender esto a todos los números
o sea incluir al 0 aunque podríamos
decidir que es 0 elevado a la 0 fuera
igual a 1 pero de este lado estamos
viendo que 0 elevado a cualquier
potencia distinta de 0 también nos da 0
entonces tal vez podríamos querer que 0
elevado a la 0 fuera igual a 0 aunque
entonces estamos en un dilema no sabemos
cuál de las dos cosas debería de ser
cierto y la verdad es que no tiene por
qué ser alguna de las dos ciertas y la
otra no o sea va a haber casos donde sea
claro que cero a la cero tiene que ser
igual a uno y habrá casos en los que sea
claro que
0 elevado a la 0 tiene que ser 0 depende
del contexto pero bueno el chiste es que
no hay una respuesta natural de cómo se
debería definir 0 a la 0 y en estos
casos lo que hacen los matemáticos es
decidir que este asunto está
indeterminado
d
en algunos casos sí es muy importante
que se define a 0 elevado a la 0 como un
1 en otros casos tiene todo el sentido
del mundo y es importante definir a 0
elevado a la 0 como cero pero no es como
que podamos decir que siempre siempre
que escribamos 0 elevado a la cero tiene
que ser igual a cero oa uno aunque
entonces 0 elevado a cualquier potencia
distinta de cero es cero cualquier
número distinto de cero elevado a la
potencia cero es 1 pero no podemos
definir de ninguna forma 0 elevado a la
cero aunque hay 0 elevado a la cero es
algo que no está determinado